and the Oscar goes to Joe : Ethan :  No Country for Old Men this is the third  Academy Award for Joe : anything :  and their second tonight  you  I I don't have a lot to add to what I  said earlier  Thank You Ethan and I have been making  stories with movie cameras since we were  kids  in the late 60s when Ethan was 11 or 12  he got a suit in a briefcase and we went  to the Minneapolis International Airport  the super 8 Cameron made a movie about  shuttle diplomacy called Henry Kissinger  man on the go and  honestly what we do now doesn't feel  that much different from what we were  doing then there are too many people to  thank for this we're really thrilled to  have received it and we're very thankful  to all of you out there for letting us  continue to play in our corner of the  sandbox so thank you very much